[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by cash app
as you know cash app is the simplest way
to send and save money and now it's the
simplest way to try and grow your money
introducing cash app investing unlike
investing tools that only let you buy
entire shares of stock cash app lets you
instantly invest as little or as much as
you want this way when your favorite of
company's stock is just a little too
expensive you can still own a piece with
as little as $1 and because cash app is
directly connected to your bank account
there are no four to five day waiting
periods for inbound transfers so you can
start investing today brokerage services
are provided by cash app investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC
and as always when you sign up for cash
app and use the promo code Congrats not
only will you instantly receive $10 but
cash app will also now donate ten
dollars to The Trevor Project an amazing
organization that provides crisis
intervention and suicide prevention
services to LGBTQ across youth across
America download cash app from the App
Store or Google Play Store today
[Music]
babies it's episode 148 of
congratulations podcast I was just
drinking water how politician is so
scared to drink water
why does so you suck Trump do it you saw
that guy Rubio do it you saw that other
guy do it now with the with the big-ass
neoprene bottle or a little [ __ ] they're
called politicians need to learn how to
[ __ ] drink a bottle of water you know
they're just so [ __ ] big or clunky or
like Trump holding it with the two
bitch-ass small hands just and then
Rubio just go get it do it why is it
gonna be a whole weird-ass thing just go
get the [ __ ] bottle like a man don't
be [ __ ] about it and that's it so all
right
look dude I got a lot of mucus going on
today I'm sorry it's fine look at the
way Trump drink drink the [ __ ] bottle
of water
Michael grow Michael Gove Michael Gove
drank it like that it's just using two
hands is [ __ ] if you're drinking a
bottle of water drink oh oh use one hand
if you're using two hands you're a baby
and not the good kind
yeah or you're you know you're you're
like a [ __ ] possum all right Trump's
a possum so uh we got dates coming up
November 29th I'm going to be in El Paso
Texas
November 30th I'm gonna be in Houston
Texas Puri Illinois December 29th these
are the last days of follow-the-leader
tour December 30th Chicago Illinois and
December 31st New Year's Eve Chicago
Chicago Illinois a lot of those are sold
out so go get your tickets I'm gonna be
in Orillia Ontario two shows there in
January 17th and 18th and then Las Vegas
in April 18th I got a these these those
are the LAT the last followed leader
tours I don't think that even the April
one in Las Vegas is gonna be follow the
leader tour I got to start writing new
chicks I just shot my special anyway go
get tickets at Chris D'Elia com get
ticket to Chris Lea com
Chris Leo calm always available all the
time so yeah I was in Florida man I love
Florida I love how it I love how it rips
dude I play Tampa two nights three shows
we did one on Wednesday oh and then hell
nah we did two on Thursday then we went
to Melbourne on Friday Melbourne Florida
by the way there's a Beverly Hills
Florida on Melbourne Florida and a
Hollywood Florida
hey Florida get your own identity you
know that's so crazy that there's so
many [ __ ] already places in Florida
already places have you been to Israel
Florida
have you been to [ __ ] in an article
Florida mmm
so no so I was in Florida I did three
shows in Dayton one show in Melbourne
and one show one big one in Fort
Lauderdale or as we like to call it for
a lot of dottie who likes to party
just to be really wide about it Fort
Lauderdale a we relaxed the party yeah
so we were in Fort Lauderdale with the
big one is almost like 5,000 people that
was awesome
um anyway dude whatever they kept
opening up sections for your boy it was
like a 3,000 seater and then we were
like hey open up the back sections open
up more and then we're like hey opened
up the back sections and when we open up
more cuz backs and also I'm gonna double
it will keep doubling it until the kill
me and that's a two-part quote so we
were in Florida
Zach Don coqui always with us tour
manager extraordinaire he laughs like
that always late to everything only tour
manager always late to everything he
says oh don't worry I won't be late this
time I know you talked about me on your
podcast ahead I'll be there 15 minutes
early every time legitimately the first
[ __ ] thing he was late at and then
also late at all of the other things but
late at the first thing late to my house
to leave for the airport oh I didn't
know there's gonna be traffic here but I
think it was Mike I think was Mike's
fault my openers fault
because he [ __ ] Michael do this thing
where he like sets up sets the alarm at
like if we have to leave at 7:20 he'll
set his alarm as it at 7:15 and they'll
be like I already packed I'm all good
this all I have to do is roll out of bed
whatever dude and then he's like I
didn't know I didn't take an account
there's gonna be traffic of course you
gotta take it in town there's gonna be
traffic remember high school though they
would be like at least in my high school
they'd be like well if you're late we
got to get you ready for real life so
you leave earlier you account for
traffic and if you're late for high
school then these jobs are just gonna
fire you dude you don't get fired if you
[ __ ] late you know everyone's like oh
yeah the traffic was crazy alright it's
all good no big deal being late is
[ __ ] shitty though dude
it really is shitty you're saying [ __ ]
you to everybody else's time but alas
we're all late every now and then but I
was in this video is the one of these
maybe of the year okay this Papa John's
interview world on W W DRB News Timothy
Burke on Twitter tweeted a clip of a
bunch of these things this guy Papa
John's got he was on a call in an
internal call that I guess leaked and he
said the n-word a bunch of times which
is so weird my old thing is even now in
2019 even if you are racist it's so
weird to not know not to do those things
even if you are racist it's so weird to
know like blackface Halloween to just be
like yeah I know I'm gonna get in
trouble but [ __ ] it or to say the n-word
and a meeting knowing it's bad this
guy's in his 50s maybe even 60 knows
it's bad and to still be like yeah but
I'm still racist gotta say the n-word
gotta just leak it out somehow in this
ins meeting I haven't said it yet today
I haven't heard the phone call what what
that it's just incredible is it out
there I wonder if you could find it I
doubt it's out there well made it's
somewhere in the dark web but anyway he
got fired or you know he stepped down or
whatever the hell happened from Papa
John's and now there's a new guy run
Papa John's Pizza obviously and this guy
who used to run the the creator the
owner of Papa John's whatever CEO Papa
John's what's his name uh I don't know
what his name is but anyway the founder
of John Shatner Schnatter John Schnatter
used the n-word on a conference call in
May yeah he looks like a guy that would
use the n-word too you know so anyway
this is a clip a bunch of clips from the
interview now that came out today W DRB
W DRB news that'll gdr be news about
today they had to sit down and by the
way the guy who is interviewing his
black which is like so interesting
because he's got to he was disgraced he
said in n-word anyway here we go
there's some stuff in the last 30 days
first of all gonna die okay first of all
gonna die that means dude that means
he's had a whole pizza for a lunch or
dinner one of the days out of the 30
days in the month and then also ten more
of those days he ate a whole pizza for
another meal a fat [ __ ] made of dough
just so much [ __ ] how's this guy not
nine hundred pounds look isn't it I've
had over 40 pizzas in the last thirty
days
livvie currently and Mark Shapiro should
be in jail okay
who's that that's the new guy Mark
Shapiro should be in jail who's Mark
Shapiro we gotta look that up as you
look that up I'm gonna keep going I've
had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days I
meant hardly and Mark Shapiro should be
in jail
he has no pizza experience he's never
been in the pizza category okay so has
no pizza experience I guess he has no
experience making pizza I guess okay
fine
never be
you can tell he doesn't give interviews
a lot you know never been in the plaits
of category Oh
I read over 40 pizzas and less three
days it's like the [ __ ] what is
supersize me documentary board members
Olivia curtly and Mark Shapiro
okay so Papa John's new leaders
including Steve Ritchie who replaced him
as CEO and the board members Olivia much
better they should be in jail do it Oh
cuz they stole the company away and now
they've destroyed the company ah man I'm
going to jail at all in any case any way
shape or form over pizza what are you
aiming for
I killed a few guys what are you in here
for I [ __ ] a few kids what are you
here for brutal eatin 40 pizzas in 30
days that's what I'm in here for why did
he sound like he [ __ ] should be in and
uh with the lights out in just the
silhouette talking in front of a like a
curtain in a holiday and like a he
sounds like an informant that's trying
to trying to remain anonymous but he's
and he's not 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
Livi currently and Mark Shapiro should
be in jail
he has no Pizza experience he's never
been in the pizza category I would just
say stay tuned the day of reckoning will
come so drunk the record will be
straight why not set the record straight
dude the day of reckoning for what dude
you said the n-word and you can't say
the n-word at a business meeting if
you're that racist just go home and let
it out [ __ ] it to nobody at night just
get home and just be like okay you know
he's just sitting there eating 40 pizzas
in 38 days just like [ __ ] [ __ ] mark
[ __ ] Mark Shapiro that's why it sounds
like that cuz he had 40 pizzas in 30
days
stay tuned the day of reckoning will
come wrecking so drunk the record will
be straight why not set the record
straight now I mean what is it about the
record that's not straight
what does he have up his [ __ ]
Pappajohn sleeve what does this guy what
does this guy know that we don't know
you know Oh stay tuned next month
I ate 50 pizzas that that's what it is
that's the day of reckoning I'm gonna
eat so many pizzas that you're not even
gonna understand how many pizzas about
the fact - this is the best part
that Papaji eaten last why is he still
wearing the [ __ ] outfit Mark Shapiro
should be in jail
he has no pizza experience that a Papa
John he's still wearing a shirt that
looks like a Papa John's shirt guy wear
blue hey guy wear grey at over 40 pizzas
in the last 30 days dude I've had over
40 pizzas in the last 30 days I've had
over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days gonna
die yeah
dude there's one that was really funny
here 40 pizzas this this made me laugh
over 40 pizzas by Timothy Burke Sam guy
he put it he's mean I've had over 40
pizzas in the last 30 days I've had over
40 pizzas in the last 30 days who has
had over 40 pizzas period dude I've had
over 40 pizzas in the last 17 years
not even that even if you've had over 40
pizzas in 10
years you're a fat pig if you have had
over 40 pizzas in the last 10 years if
you've had over 40 pizzas in the last 10
years you're a pig it's like the [ __ ]
the guys on the QVC we have got 40
pizzas and we don't have them in the
last 10 years we don't have the last 40
pizzas in the last five years we don't
how can we go lower we don't have the
last 40 pizzas in the last three and a
half years we know that can we go lower
let me check hold on let me check and
make sure we can go lower
we don't have 40 pizzas in the last one
year we don't have less we don't have 40
pizzas in the last year we eat we eat 40
pizzas
we don't eat 40 pizzas in the last six
months can you believe that we don't
need we don't eat 40 pizzas in the last
six months we donate 40 pizzas in the
last four months
we don't need over 40 pizzas in the last
two months for a limited time only right
now for a limited time only now I've had
over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days for a
limited time only 40 pizzas over 40
pizzas in the last 30 days
call now we've got look at these
beautiful
says we've got pepperoni we've got
cheese we've got pepperoni we've got
sausage we've got meat lover you've been
able to get a pit meat livers we have
got veggie pizzas
you could have onions on them you have
onions off we have margherita pizzas we
have barbecue chicken pizza for some
reason we have Hawaiian pizzas even
though pineapple doesn't belong on pizza
and everybody knows that with over four
pizzas in third days also who's counting
dude imagine eating and imagine getting
to your seventh pizza and being like
seven dude my favorite thread though
under this was because the guy looks
really shiny and he and somebody write
writes why is he so wet and then
somebody under dydt under it writes he's
had 40 pizzas unless that make you wet
i'm a little hard at it then somebody
wrote there are two kinds of people one
in the pizza category two criminals [ __ ]
oh god that [ __ ] that's a meme for the
ages bro somebody wrote it made it
whatever
ESPN 4430 big papa ESPN films 44 30
that's funny
[ __ ] this guy I love out-of-touch people
it's so funny
sound like that why does he sound like
that oh man I wish there was audio of
him saying the n-word that would be so
funny and bad and weird that's from a
guy who eats 40 pizzas though bro I
don't know anyway
ah [ __ ] that makes me laugh so I was in
Florida I ate I actually ate a pizza in
Florida I won't eat some less 30 days I
ate one pizza
I felt like trash I I actually ate
[ __ ] one pizza one night a big one
and then the next night there was
nothing to eat in Melbourne and we
ordered a [ __ ] Papa John's do it
I just remembered this we ordered Papa
John's we got [ __ ] Turtles and I ate
my [ __ ] cheese puzzle and then and
then Mike and Zach got one and I never
eat oh I didn't get a cheese piece I got
veggie pizza cuz I'm trying to be
healthy hilarious and they got Hawaiian
pizza and that's gross dude I pineapple
is a [ __ ] amazing huh
pineapple is so good you know it really
is just in a flame or explosion in your
[ __ ] mouth if you don't like
pineapple I get it but if you like
pineapple I super get it you understand
what I'm saying put it this way if there
was ever gonna be a fruit in spiked
armor it would be pineapple because
that's the one that tastes jammin you
understand that's the one that tastes
like for dilute solutions that's the
fruit that's the bangin hot new hotness
fruit dude
if any fruit was gonna be covered in
spiked armor it would be a fruit that
tastes like that if it was an apple
you'd be like it's not worth it to it
apples are great but they're as good as
their skin you understand pineapple I
used to have this joke where I was like
hey pineapple
why are you [ __ ] in spiked armor
what's in there
$40 stupid joke funny enough uh but
40 grand I don't remember what the
[ __ ] thing was it was stupid but why
is it so spiky you know like what was
the deal
this whole evolution of pineapple is
crazy man you know what should be in a
[ __ ] armor is [ __ ] peak boots oh
that's so good pizza is so good and I
can't stand a hookers keep talking about
it on Instagram but it is dude
pizzas so bangin every time you take a
bite of pizza it's like this
[Music]
alright dude here we go blue apron I
love blue apron and guess what I'm a
cook now babies I never was a cook now
amok when was the last time you made a
dinner you were proud of me I make about
freedom for over three days because of
blue apron making meals with blue apron
his science meets art it's creating
something delicious and harmonious it's
evenings that take everyone away from
computers and phones and put them
together in the heat of the moment the
heat of the kitchen because when you
make dinner with blue apron you're not
just cooking you're creating blue apron
offers a flexible menu options they
offer flexible menu options with
ever-changing mix of meat fish plant
forward and vegetarian recipes it's
great blue aprons menu is carefully
designed and tested by our Test Kitchen
chefs our Test Kitchen uses unique
specialty ingredients to bring chef
quality recipes to your dinner table
upcoming meals include chicken black
bean and kale enchiladas mmm
sesame sweet chili wonton noodles you
kiddin me beyond meat bolognaise
seriously crispy potato and kale hash
YUM blue apron believes cooking matters
don't have it delivered precooked or
picked up cook it cook it once a week
once a month or at least once more than
you do now or at least for each one of
them three thes check out this week's
menu and get sixty dollars of when you
visit blue apron sixty dollars off when
you visit blue apron comstock Congrats
that's blue apron com / Congrats blue
apron just cook now every time I read of
every time I read off I think of but
whatever manscaped support for
congratulations comes from manscaped who
is number one in men's below the belt
grooming manscaped offers
precision-engineered tools for your
family jewels I nicked my balls I have
before
ever since got on board with manscape
never nicked my balls my balls are very
uh I I almost feel like they're sturdier
now because of this because don't Nick
them anymore manscaped has redesigned
the electric trimmer their lawn mower
2.0 as proprietary skin safe technology
so this trimmer won't neck or snag your
nuts manscaping accidents are finally a
thing of the past
they've also manscaped also has the crop
preserver it's an anti chafing ball
deodorant and moisturizer you put your
dirt under your armpits
hello your balls are more important than
your armpits so use it for your balls to
get 20% off free shipping with the code
congrats at manscaped comm get 20% off
free shipping and a free travel bag with
the code congrats at men scape comm
that's 20% off with free shipping and a
free travel bag at manscaped calm and
use code Congrats yeah so that's what's
up
man how many times I say that's what's
up in this podcast I could that do you
say that I'd say that's what's up one I
don't really know what's going on I was
in Florida and when I was in Florida I
was in Tampa and Batista my buddy Dave
Batista wrestling and acting and action
movie action movie star extraordinaire
was invited me
well first away came to the show which
was awesome came to the show and it was
funny too because he was like we're in
third
oh man aye aye beforehand he was like
you'll be able to see us out there and I
was like ah you know it's a good thing
that the lights kind of blind you can't
see anybody so don't worry about that
and then I got on stage was the only
theater that I could see like the first
four rows ever and I just I'm doing
stand-up in Dave Bautista just and it's
staring right at me
so weird you know in Tampa Florida and
so but it was great to have him out
there he was laughing with his friends
and and then the next day he invited me
to go to his gym which is like a gym he
owns it's like his office and gym that
he built they bought the property and
then built it and it's so awesome dude
he's got like boxing uh punching he has
punching bags he has mixed martial arts
mat and my opener went to go step on it
with his shoes dude I almost put him in
a [ __ ] all shot I got a right there
dude because I almost put him in a
[ __ ] Kim Mora do it I almost put him
in a [ __ ] weird Nick it took right
there because it almost put his [ __ ]
shoes on des petites his martial arts
mat uh anyway was over there training at
his gym it's really cool that he has
that gym dude I want to have that I want
to have a gym so that's my goal now is
having a gym but like an actual full gym
not like a makeshift gym or like a half
gym the guy has everything he's got I
mean he has dead he has the [ __ ] uh
squat rack you got [ __ ] all to do the
deadlift he got the deadlift plates I
mean he's got all of this [ __ ] he's got
the chains that for some reason people
workout with they have chains you know
like you're Hercules that's a weird one
to just have the chains when we're guys
are like I work out so hard that I gotta
have chains around my neck you know I
get to change away something but it's
like just use an extra plate you know i
strongiy you gotta be the Aussie guys
changed on you the rock does it so it's
got to be good
but it was cool that he invited me in
and Mike my opener over to work out he's
got his own like like art around and his
weights have his silhouette on with a
[ __ ] sword because of course it does
you know and he's got it all hooked up
dude the system in Blair and my buddy
put his man Mike put his [ __ ] eye
iPhone on and it was like would put you
put on some music and he put on some
music it was like [ __ ] two good songs
before hozier started loser started
playing or whatever it's like dude we'll
work it out we're not trying to fall in
love anyway
and then David did sound nice Dave
Batista is he was like he was like hey
man ordered you a Pokeball after you're
done working out I'm like yeah all right
this guy's the nicest nicest [ __ ] dude
he wrote me a nice message after my show
and I aspire to be as friendly and nice
as he because he like have you seen
these videos like Keanu Reeves did you
see the one of counter Reeves got with
the on the bus where the flight was was
when was that the flight was like
delayed it was this year right and let
me just pull this up Keanu Reeves
Airport Airport van here we go
Keanu Reeves and co-passengers road trip
back to LA oh because he was in Barstow
and they couldn't fly back or something
but Bakersfield yeah so I got on a plane
with Keanu Reeves he was very pleasant
took photos talked about latest project
with two variant it our play McKenna was
diverted to big reveals hold on an
announcement
[Music]
ken was cool so far
they just announcement maybe talking
maybe taking a bus the airport here in
Bakersfield was closed there were no
employees but they did open a blimpy for
the counter got up also airline
employees in route to airport
can eyes a question
anyway they got him a bus
they took a bus might be running a bus
we kind of he chose to stay and wait a
hanging Bakersfield or get on a bus with
Keano
he's got the speed thing okay so Kendell
gets on the bus California now this guy
this is two hour drive back to LA
encounter just sitting there and people
are just filming in in the bus like
could be so awkward and this guy Canada
has just love and look counter even
walking into cause jr. and he just like
they were there were only five goodbyes
are always sad but counters kept it
together finally arrived
man I just counter eases attitude is so
good dude I mean it's just I I want to
be that positive and I just I think that
all that I think that all the time and
then something happens and it's all out
the window dude I want to be positive I
told you about the story in the podcast
when I went to the John wick to premiere
and I was like sitting there and I
[ __ ] got to see counter he's finally
has been a big counter ease fan for a
long time and everyone is loving
calories now and I'm like the guy the
annoying guy in high school that's like
yeah but I knew the band before they
started dude I was I been through it
with kyon oh I loved kyon who ever since
Bill and Ted as a kid I loved Kiana
never did I DEP always people were like
oh he's not a good actor bro
[ __ ] y'all okay and I don't mean to say
y'all he is a good actor and he's also
the last movie star straight up but but
so I was at the John wick to premiere
and then I think I told you the story
but I was so excited to see Kenner he's
gonna get up and talk in front everybody
so he does and he's like thank you very
much and as he's leaving somebody behind
me goes hey Keanu and does a [ __ ]
line from Point Break and I'm like this
[ __ ] gonna make this moment
about him I'm so pissed off at this guy
making this moment about Keanu Reeves
making this moment about him when it
should be about count of reeves and
everyone gets to share this experience
but this guy's calling out hoechlin
calories this [ __ ] amped her I'm
so angry and then I look back at
canneries Carrie's is smiling and did
the other line from the movie and I was
like oh that's the difference between a
nice guy and to me the [ __ ]
Canterbury's taught me about life and he
doesn't even know it dude
the the positivity that this guy has
just so grateful and I want to be like
that every day I think I want to be like
that and then every day something
happens
and we get back to well go [ __ ] yourself
at least I have that no I mean I'm not
even 40 I'm the youngest guy you ever
[ __ ] met but at least I still I have
some life experience at least at least I
still am hanging on to that I want to be
positive it all starts with there I'm at
the bottom step I'm at the bottom rung
of it you know what I'm talking about
I'm at the bottom rung of it and at
least I'm at the bottom rung of it at
least I'm not underground you know cuz
some guys are like that [ __ ] being
positive the world's negative I'm a
negative guy [ __ ] it you can't beat them
join them
I'm a troll right no I won't be that I
won't be that I want to be positive but
as soon as I step out to a [ __ ] thing
and then somebody's like hey bro nah
that's it dude you want to talk I'm not
Keano anymore I'm kinda in my head as
soon as you want to talk that's it dude
back to Chris D'Elia don't [ __ ] this up
for me dude I'm trying to live that
Keano lifestyle I'll try to live that
Keano lifestyle and you're trying to
[ __ ] it up for me by talking you know
what I mean by saying hey what are you
from hey dude loved you in workaholics
alright cool that's it
I'm out I'm out back to Chris D'Elia
baby we can we all be as positive
positive as Keanu Reeves in a [ __ ]
van from Bakersfield to LA imagine how
[ __ ] mad I be dude imagine how
[ __ ] mad my blood when we first of
all this is how it goes we're diverting
to Bakersfield actually this is me what
we're diverting the Bakersfield we can't
get to the why hey hello
hey why well we can't oh well you're
gonna have to otherwise I get up
I get mad well we're just gonna okay
who shall we land oh cool hey there's no
plane or employees i bring the thing
with me
I bring the button with me oh I'm out of
the plane I bring the button with me and
I put it up to where I'm sitting I put
it on above me and I go boom and I say
where's the flight attendant I should
still be on the plane so I should still
have a flight attendant we landed early
bring me a [ __ ] flight attendant yes
where's the new plane where there isn't
one oh yeah whoa congratulations I live
in Barstow now [ __ ] it I'm where I
should be because that's when we land
where we should so I won't accept that
we're in in Bakersfield Barstow where
the [ __ ] is the same thing I won't
accept them in Bakersfield wherever I am
this is home cuz that's where I thought
it was going you take me home this is
home buy me a couch
buy me walls buy me heat buy me food set
me the [ __ ] up I live here now that's my
attitude and Ken if I was on that plane
with the counter Karen I'll be like well
you know maybe look let's just go take a
bus hey man I don't think you're
listening to me dude
I'll live here this is my home and Karen
oh just let's take a boss the only
reason why I'd get on that bus is if I
was with Keanu and then imagine somebody
looking at a man speed all over again
huh how mad I would be if I was ya know
don't bring up my [ __ ] movies in real
can we just chill don't record me dude
but this guy's just loving it bro
constantly sure film sure let's take a
bus diverting no prob
there's no employees all you got to eat
is Blimpie's this guy's just loving it
this guy a Blimpie's and caused you and
stop to get four Carl's jr. unfuckin
real
so that's amazing let's do more ads
tipsy elves dude
they sent me pants and a shirt that says
make the Yuletide gay and it's very
colorful and very hip it's officially
the holidays and no party is complete
without getting your ultra festive
holiday clothing from tipsy elves tipsy
elves is the one-stop shop for all your
holiday clothing needs they sell a
one-of-a-kind Christmas
they sell one-of-a-kind Christmas
sweaters dresses family pajamas and
onesies that will transform your holiday
party into an unforgettable experience
you will be the life of the party with
the tipsy elves they have hilarious
designs till tipsy elves hilarious
sweaters that will have everyone at the
party laughing you want to be the life
of the party get up with tipsy elves
interactive sweaters skip the small talk
and bring the front of the party from
drinking game sweaters detect insulin
lights look it's fun dude women's men's
plus sizing wide range of styles and
sizes so get the comfortable fit they
carry Plus sizes so fat you can get it
onesies matching pajamas teachers I mean
they got it all Christmas suits dude you
think they stopped at leggings nah they
got leggings uh say snow thank you too
boring this year
try one of the hilariously awesome
designs from tipsy elves go to tipsy
elves calm slash Congrats now get 20%
off your entire order your entire order
that's tipsy elves Comstock's congrats
for 20% off today they make great gifts
get it now give it for Christmas my
bookie attention past present and future
my bookie players during Thanksgiving
week my bookie is offering a risk-free
bet on the Bears Lions game simply
choose a team against the spread for up
to $250 if you win Congrats you got
extra holiday spending money if you lose
congratulations to you as well
my bookie will give you all your money
back it's a no brainer because you
literally cannot lose it's no risk all
gravy that's really weird that they're
doing that but they're doing that
okay so congratulations guys it doesn't
matter whether you
an experienced player or a first-time
customer my bookie welcomes all to come
to come play so quit waiting around and
sign up today it's awesome just log on
to my bookie AG and make your first
deposit with promo code congrats and my
bookie will match your deposit dollar
for dollar to jumpstart your bankroll
and that's on top of the risk free bet
let me repeat that's a guaranteed
deposit match and a risk-free bet for
Thanksgiving only so if you're a true
football fan you do not want to let this
opportunity pass you by you simply
cannot lose Genest and you know what
losing is right can't do that here make
sure you do your part to support your
team this season hop on the gravy train
and get in on the action with my bookie
you play you win you get paid
congratulations is brought to you by
cash up the official app of the law
cabin
so anyway babies that's what's up that's
what I say after all the ads this guy
keeps asking me although one second I'm
respectful yes alright people ask me a
bunch of stuff and I get pissed you see
that person I got a tattoo of did you
see this I got a Sindhi you know I've
Instagram guy got a tattoo I'll send it
to you guy got a tattoo of me like
straight-up hardcore really good artwork
like I've I don't know who got it but
mike mike purdy tattoo on instagram
posted it you got a tattoo of my face
it's like really well done so weird it's
so weird to get a really lifelike
portrait of someone's face on your body
you already have a face to have another
face on your body is crazy to me my
buddy Dean del Rey has a [ __ ] rocker
on this his side and somebody was in an
argument with him once about the guy and
he was like yeah this and that about the
singer he's like no it's not he was like
nor that singer did do that he was like
no he didn't he was like well you think
you know more about
singer than I do and he goes yeah look
and he pulled up the side of his shirt
how to [ __ ] the guy's face on the
side of his body dude I laughed like how
40 Prince's in 30 days I'm gonna get 40
pizzas on my tattooed on my body like
like Tupac how he had the [ __ ] 50
anwered honest I'm gonna get 40
preachers right there in the middle of
my chest
thug life terrible mobility that a
bumboat anyway come see me in Houston
and come see me and all why can't the
same and see me in Paso dude I was
thinking about this I was when I was a
kid I was terrified of the dentist like
a basic kid like just terrified of the
of the dentist which is stupid
and I started think about kids stories I
told the Freddy Krueger story again on
on my podcast about the about [ __ ]
my pants on my friend and my friend
sleepover [ __ ] my pants
and and so I was thinking about the time
my dad brought me to the dentist and I
don't know what my dad did I think my
dad did it because my mom was like Chris
is so scared about going that design I
want to deal with this [ __ ] so my dad
stayed home from work and brought me to
the dentist and I remember when he
brought me I was like that I'm so scared
I don't want the dentist to do what he
does and put his [ __ ] tools on my
mouth and he was like you're gonna be
fine it'll be okay don't worry about it
you'll be fine got to the dentist's
office and the dentist was like a really
nice guy my dad was friends with him and
[ __ ] I think but I don't think he was
like friends first and then then became
the dentist I think like it was like
friends because he was a like a fun
dentist anyway so I got there and the
guy was trying to be so that this was
gonna be so good and like showing me
toys and like you get a prize if you do
this and and I was just scared out of my
mind and I was crying I think to be
brutally honest with you guys
and I was like I don't know about I
don't know about this I don't know I
don't know and he was like trying to get
in my mouth sounds really gross and so
and I couldn't do it and I just couldn't
bring myself to do it and I got up and I
walked to another chair and I sat down
and minutes went by I mean a lot of
minutes went by and my dad was like I
gotta get to work buddy I can't do this
so let's leave we'll do it again another
time and I was like okay and and we left
and I didn't do it and driving home I
was like he was like I know you're
scared but it's really okay like it's
not a big deal I promise you and
something like clicked in my brain and I
was like okay is there still time to do
it if I go do it now and he's like I
guess so sure yeah yeah if you don't do
it now we could do it and I said okay I
can do it he said okay but if we go back
then you got to do it for real and I was
like no I can do it okay
I'll really do it and I went back I
walked right into that doctor's the
dentist's office and he clean my teeth
and I remember as a kid feeling so good
about the fact that I had to overcome my
fear granted ridiculous fear but still I
was scared and it made me think about
how fear is just you know especially if
you're scared of something where
nothing's really gonna happen like a
dentist or talking in front of people
some people are scared of that so we've
got her scared of you know playing the
big game or whatever the [ __ ] it is or
her or running for office whatever the
[ __ ] it is you know like it's all that
kind of fear is all made up like fear
you know being in the middle of a jungle
and not having food obviously is really
scary or something like that or being
your or going skydiving or whatever the
[ __ ] but fear where nothing is really
gonna happen nothing is really on the
line like like it's all made up dude
like you just made it up you're scared
of not a thing going being scared going
to the dentist isn't really a fear you
know and if you're six years old that's
fine they can't explain that to a
six-year-old now that I'm a [ __ ] in
my 30s
so young still but like you can just do
the things I remember the first time
ever did stand up I was scared and I was
thinking like it's weird it's just going
up in front of people and talking to
them and I remember taking my cell I was
like if I just moved my legs if I just
take a step toward the stage one at a
time I remember breaking this down and
thinking like move my right leg move my
left leg move my right leg move my left
leg just keep doing that that's walking
once I get on stage I'll then I'll be on
stage and that's and then I just have to
start talking and that'll be doing
stand-up you know and it remember just
breaking it down like as a as a kid too
if I just do it if I go walk over and
get to that dentist chair I'll be in the
dentist chair and then there's nothing I
can do I'm already halfway done base I'm
already done basically if I decide if
you decide to do something that's all
you're done if you decide to do it
you're done if you fully decide to do
something you already did it because
it's gonna happen do you understand take
working out you're you're fat or you
want to lose weight or you're not in
shape you say you know what I want to go
work out today but I don't want to go
work out today but I've already decided
I'm gonna do it so you know that it's
done because you're gonna do it you
create the [ __ ] [ __ ] you create your
day you create your destiny right I hate
when people say [ __ ] like that but it's
you know you don't create you all of
your destiny but you create those
[ __ ] things it's done I already got
my teeth cleaned it's done when is it
tomorrow well it didn't happen yet yeah
it did because I decided for that [ __ ]
to happen my sunglasses are on right now
no it's not no they're not I'm looking
at you yeah but I already decided that
they're gonna go on so that means
there's good as on the futures tube ride
I'm telling you dude once you get that
mentality man and I'm no life coach but
I'm a [ __ ] life coach dude once you
get that mentality of it's done
I decided that this is going to happen
it is
so whoever needs to hear this rivers
listening to the [ __ ] whether you're in
your cubicle you're driving to work
you're at the beach or listening to this
[ __ ] at the gym it's done if you decided
now but I want to go home now okay then
that's what you decided then that's done
yeah but I should do one more set then
you already decided it's done you know
oh that's how I get [ __ ] done I decide
to do it it's really as easy as that
dude
it really is you didn't decide to do it
if you didn't [ __ ] do it it's about
the decision anyway dude that's annoying
that I said all that what's kind of true
my dad would always say you know people
would say how did you know you wanted to
be a director he's a director you know
and he would say well you decide you're
a director and you'd be like what it's
not that easy and he said yeah but he
would always say this he was like Popeye
doesn't walk around saying I'm gonna be
Popeye he's [ __ ] Popeye and I was
like yeah even though that sounds so
dumb it's so true
I love simple [ __ ] like that Popeyes
Popeye dude um by the way he's on before
the calamari story I told ya last week
he was like I know you don't have guests
on your podcast but I want to [ __ ]
call in um maybe I should call him right
now I wonder if he'll pick up let me see
if I pick up
bill D'Elia let's do it here let me make
sure that even they've been but he's not
doing anything I'm calling my dad what
are you doing yo you want to want to I'm
um I'm on my podcast you want to talk
about your calamari thing here I'll put
you on speaker
go ahead state your [ __ ] claim ok so
my claim is you can't slam a guy for the
way he eats calamari first of all you're
wrong you're wrong
go ahead incorrect ok because because
because first of all you your claim is
that somebody eats calamari
should know how they like to eat
calamari should know that they like
that's [ __ ] no because you can like
to eat calamari with sauce and without
sauce yeah I know but each calamari you
eat you should know how much sauce you
want it for that calamari no your each
one you eat if you like it with sauce or
without sauce you should be able to
decide ok I like that's crazy dude in
the way you eat something but but but it
if you have listen if you have ok so
here's what happened you had the [ __ ]
calamari
oh you had to Calamari's on the thing
you poked one good good through and then
you poked another one and it was
dangling off ok and I and I knew it was
gonna fall off in the sauce and you
[ __ ] it fell off in the sauce and
then you ate the one with half the sauce
on it and then you just dip your fork
and got the other one put it in the fit
in your mouth
and you liked both of those the same
amount of ways yes no you're lying
ok so then you don't care
you don't allow for the for the fact
that someone could like both versions of
that you don't allow that okay okay so
if you were gonna order calamari
alright if you were gonna order [ __ ]
alright so okay okay okay so if you were
gonna order calamari and they said okay
but just so you know we ran out of sauce
you'd still get two calamari yes okay
what if they said okay just so you know
just so you know we got the calamari but
we we dropped them all in the sauce and
everywhere and we just basically have a
a plate of calamari but it's all got
sauce all over it you'd you'd say yes to
that too like way better it was all in
sauce okay so so you're saying that
because you dropped it in the sauce it
doesn't matter that much but you still
like it that way and it and yeah see
that's the kind of thing where I just
it's like if a guy like that you can
trust less than a guy who knows how he
likes his calamari that's what I'm
saying you like me less no I don't like
you less but it's like you're the guy in
the movie that like double-crosses
someone but no you aren't that guy but
if you were in a book if your character
was in a book and like they were like
and he was eating calamari and one
dropped off in the sauce and he still
ate it just like he ate the one without
the sauce you and then that guy went on
page like 600 700 and he like [ __ ]
took the the the the hero of the of the
story for a ride and was like a dick
about it
he'd be like oh okay
I get it the foreshadowing was the
[ __ ] calamari eating okay bottom line
bottom line yeah I accept your apology
there's no [ __ ] apology dude you're
the guy I told you this but you're the
guy who gets the [ __ ] truck with the
flatbed and gets the top over it because
he doesn't know how he wants his [ __ ]
truck yeah I get that all right I love
you and that's where I kiss you on the
face every [ __ ] time it's in my eye
it's in my eye about whatever it's too
high mom knows you make it be about your
eye but it's on your cheek
whatever man you know where you want to
kiss [ __ ] and that's the ID you
should know how to have your calamari
all right all right I'll talk to you
later love you it's a wrong number all
right you guys there you have it you
wanted to call it in status claim and
that's what's up with the calamari [ __ ]
and that's it dude we're done we'll end
on that download download the cash app
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market text me eight one eight two three
nine seventy eighty seven and you could
text me and I try to respond to as many
people as I can I mean I get so many
texts but hit me up subscribe to the
YouTube channel subscribe rate and
review the show on iTunes that really
helps thank you very much come see me
now come see me in El Paso and Houston
and Chicago and Peoria and you is coming
out in December and my new special my
new special is coming out next year we
got a lot of stuff going on and then
army of the day army of the Dead is
coming out next year - so thanks for
this thanks for listening and you guys
are great
see
[Music]